let's quickly review we can adjust it
last time and I'm just gonna show you a
slightly new result has anyone finished
one tries one 14a okay good
we'll be able to move into 14b which is
about graphing but I do want to show you
something quickly in which are those of
you who finish will have been counted
already but it's a it's a result work
for me so firstly but just think about
conversion right these new units okay
what was the one equation which has have
been probably the key through all of
your conversions yes okay so you're
thinking about I actually met between
radians in two days I'll get to my L and
ratio in a minute if I think about
radians and degrees and how they fit
together
I'm gonna go with PI radians which is
equal to 180 degrees if you start from
there you're very very quickly able to
convert back and forth and you would
come you ain't confused which way
Swedish okay so I always write that one
down
and I don't bother with any of the other
ones I don't bother with clown 180 or
185 cuz I always confuse them with each
other but people never confuse that
one's that wonderfully yeah
geometrically speaking we have already
discovered that if I have say something
like
and al-qaeda he I can't alcohol be son
this particular angular have a power
radius in my circles like the very first
place that we started in terms of
formulas was up late and odd length
comes right out of the very definition
of what radians are it's the ratio
between arc length and radius right so
we said that L was equal to Z about just
popping up like them that's of it could
not get any more simple okay
after ugly we looked at in comparison
with a definite area right so for
example here I'm gonna be mcmoney
coldest fever as well
if behind the area I'm just getting to
different ah we call this shape a sector
the sector area is a equals money now
obviously we haven't asked Square in
there because that's where the we're
based on PI R squared cuz I want some
proportion of it there does it'll
remember what my formula is going to be
Saturn fraction uh-huh R squared
yup fantastic so these are kind of your
like bread-and-butter results is what
result that comes out of that which is
not in his comment but it's very very
elegant and simple and it's beautiful to
see which is what I'm going to show you
right now my feather mass color if I
draw one more sector here right you can
see it not at least two tens these two
intervals not only sit in a step time
they also subtend
this shape over here right this is like
if I took a circle and a sliced an edge
of things everyone know what it's called
also start to this it's a segment it's a
segment
yeah correct they are just like with our
objectives and that kind of thing you
have in fact this interval that runs
forward has actually cut off not just
one segment but two I basically obvious
one it's smaller than the other one so
we call this one the - same with the
other segment yeah it's it's the other
part of the circle right it's like that
joke when you walk up to a cake and cut
off will do a slice and then you leave
little slice there and take the rest of
them okay so here I've got a minus Sigma
W and a major segment
if I call this a birdfeeder I'm calling
it red leader okay I've got the radar
there if I want to know what the area of
this segment is all I do is do my
subtraction do you say that it's the
subtraction it's a different experience
if you start with this sector I know
what the Arabic Center is and you take
away this triangle which is dotted then
you'll be left with this segment do you
agree with that so I'm gonna call this a
secretary
like we just said you start with the
sector which we've just said is hot
hospital but then what you want to do is
take away that triangle now we know a
few different ways to work out the area
of a triangle the best way depends kind
of on what information that you have
what's the normal what's the first
formula for the area of a triangle that
you learn half based on time right now
this is great in cases where you have a
base and a perpendicular height I don't
have I well I mean I I suppose I can
make this a base but you know it doesn't
matter which ones which I don't have a
perpendicular height certainly unless
I've got some 90-degree angles and they
were just sort of so what's our other
way of working at the area huh huh a B
side C right and that C may indicate
it's the included angle yes it's the
ones between a and B okay
a you have a look at this I have exactly
all this piece of information I have
it's just science there by a of eight I
happen to be the same way
let me put an angle is
so when I working at that area for this
solution
it's a half a B is our times art it's a
square and then I go to sign of the
included a group which is just a sign of
the other right that's really nice
because they look at this I just take
out my common factor and look at the
simplicity elegance of that little
formula it's really nice and very sort
of content now keep in mind right this
is a perfect example mean all of these
are fun right but this is a perfect
example of why these these formulas they
they come right out of what radians are
and then work in degrees you can't
possibly do this in degrees right if
this angle is like you know 70 degrees
is always better this thing over here is
always gonna be less than one
these things are not going to really
compare to each other so students will
frequently evaluate this formula or the
attacker is we've not remember to change
the the mode that they're in so they'll
copy the wrong units and when they put
it oh yeah it's like it's simplifying or
whatever it is their area ends up being
astronomically larger than the entire
circle itself which clearly doesn't make
sense so this is a good area I will also
come up with a fictive comment later and
this is a nice result
now what were then going to move onto in
14b is we're gonna move away from
samples okay because remember I said
Radian measure radians as a unit or unit
for each of these two for two reasons do
better whether two reasons are circles
circles and then calculus
now since circles was the accessible
part and it is how we define it so
that's where we begin but we very
quickly go away from it so that's why
the next exercise is about graphic it
just begins with all your regular things
all your regular graphs
and says look you know how to graph
these in degrees can you get your head
into the space and a basket of
ingredients okay
so for those of you who are up to watch
a bit a lot of professional design let's
just quickly get this in a head if I say
okay here's the site curve right
I'm thinking it radiates down this is
what's true what I'm going to do don't
worry about that I think enough PI
radians to parades or anything
what's the period of the psycho from not
two so that's why I've got an
intercepted play where are the
stationery for this where is it turn
around
okay I'm used to say at dye agrees but
that's apply on two and three plug can I
just make a note by the way one of the
great these are that is is that when you
look at all of this in terms of
Blackburn proportions it makes it really
easy to see how far along you are like
although this is three quarters along
right that's how far I have to go
what's three quarters of to which is
real too I want you do the Sun there cos
curve so we're getting exactly the same
kinds of numbers but the features are
different sports so for example there
are three stationary points that I've
drawn here for the Aquatica right where
are they they're at 2 pi and
there and pine right that course was the
fact that my intercepts therefore for
cosine are at pilot two and three points
the fact that all of those numbers lined
up so neatly not a coincidence right and
lastly when we have a look at our tanker
we know that the period is half the
period is no longer two pipe right what
would that make the period of the tanker
Iranians right so therefore here is
parents right in the middle okay you're
going to go up to the acetate what is
the assets right now it's not going to
be a breeze it's play on - why is it
platitude because the tanker is sign on
cause right and look car this is zero so
therefore to buy in Missouri does it
exist that's why you get it's a
certificate that tells you there's also
an acetone degree plan on - and then
here are your two plants in the middle
so you're going to begin getting used to
thinking of these in radians I promise
once you get anywhere you serve they're
actually much more comfortable to work
with but it takes